hello before I begin the program I did
want to let you know that Goya Toledo
was supposed to join us this evening but
unfortunately she was not feeling well
so she's not here tonight so I just
wanted to let you know I'm sorry I'm
what about that film I'm going to spend
those huh please help me welcome to the
stage Grammy award-winning producer
Songer artists and two-time Oscar winner
Gustavo Santaolalla that's a master what
a film that is a Fellman so I apologize
because I have all these questions but
I'm so moved
17 years later he's amazing it's amazing
nation I actually worked on this film I
did I worked on the PR and we met then
and I remember the very first time I saw
it was on a VHS before I met Alejandro
and the studio sent it to me so that I
can see it prior to the marketing
meeting and I remember how moved I was
and how I understood that Alejandro
was just an installation filmmaker that
was just the beginning of it but I also
remember even on that VHS the insuk and
the instrumentals that completely made
me feel things that I didn't know that I
could feel and that was your work your
master so congratulations well thank you
so much it's a very personal and film
and very special film for me because
this kind of like marked a new face in
my career you know I've work for many
years as an artist and as a producer of
many
alternative Latin groups and artists and
actually you know I mean I've always
been a big fan of films and I always
thought about I've been always told that
my music was very visual and my
productions were very visual but you
know never had the opportunity I did a
couple of things many many years ago but
the story with Alejandra with this movie
is also very very special and and funny
in a way because at the time that I was
contacted to do the movie you know yeah
I was really busy producing a lot of
other stuff you know accented what I was
traveling to Argentina and I'm very very
busy with productions and I really
didn't know how I was going to do this
movie you know I got contact we had a
common friend Lynn Feinstein that was a
friend of Alejandro and a friend of me
and you know and she was telling me you
know you have to you know you have to
make the music for this you know it's a
first film of this filmmaker from Mexico
but you know you you really you know you
should do the music and and you know
I've never seen anything by Alejandro I
never got a script of you know for the
movie I never saw a rough cut or
anything you know and I was so busy that
at certain point I remember I said you
know listen you know call tomorrow -
Alejandro don't call tomorrow lean a
Mexico and said you know that I'm I'm
nice I'm not going to be able to this
film you know I'm so so busy I've never
seen anything you know and so I went
home and that night it's it absolutely
true story I woke up in the middle of
the night not you know sweating or
anything but I woke up in the middle of
the night and I just start to think you
know what if I mean what if this guy
what if this is it you know it's a
genius this guy what if this film is
amazing and I'm just saying no you know
so next morning I said you know is it
good and you know cancel that call just
you know call and say that if they come
to Los Angeles and they show me the
movie I will consider it you know and
sure enough alejandro
which in those days was a chain smoker
came to our place you know and put the
VHS and you know and I was there with my
partner of many many years and he well
you know couple that we work my engineer
and co-producer and stuff and well you
guys just so you know the first five
minutes of the movie that car chase with
a dog lair and I remember we looked with
so like five minutes we're looking at
the film you look at each other with a
new way when we're doing this film you
know we said you know we decide there
general right on the spot to to do the
film but it was another decision like
that I almost we almost didn't make the
film you know but did you read the
script no no no no never no never read
the script never saw it right this was
the Alejandra actually came with the VHS
put the film on and after watching five
minutes of the film I knew I was gonna
do the film but that you know actually
led to so much more so this was you know
the beginning for me of getting it into
you know doing music for films and
Alejandro has been so important in that
in that in this phase of my career I
mean I learned so much working with him
and I mean I could also apply lots of
things that I that I always wanted to
try you know an experiment with the use
of silence the use of textures lots of
things that that a movie like this
allowed me to to try and to use so what
was the process for the the music
because it is very specific when the
instruments come in and well you know I
have to say Alejandro has what are the
things about working with other
countries that he has very very clear
what he wants and what he's looking for
you know and it's always open to
suggestions but he really he really
knows what he wants I mean he was really
you know way fascinated with some of the
instruments that I play you know he
loved the fact that I use like the PVC
pipe you know that I've played today and
other piece of
water pipe or something you know and all
these cans and textures I'm Myron Rocco
I mean he was really fascinated with
that he was also looking for for an
electric guitar and I kind of moved him
towards that guitar with a vibrato and
and really the dirtiness the greediness
you know I mean we were really looking
for for textures but he had very clear
meaning one of the things if you notice
in the movie it takes I think almost
like 20 minutes until really a piece of
music kicks in it's there's a lot of
beginning of a whole film you know it
goes by goes mine there's really no no
music and the first thing is actually a
control my Chitti so si si señor that's
the first actually music that that kicks
in the film and by then we're already
like 20 minutes into a film so when you
saw the film there was no music
whatsoever no control my jetty
no control what you did there was you
know some temp stuff but really nothing
nothing really when there was much less
music yes and so you and and Alejandro
and was Lin involved in that process as
well Lin who didn't participate in that
process no no Lin was more in the
licensing songs and proposing sounds to
to Alejandro more with a you know Lou
Cherokee Gandhism you know things like
that but now Lin didn't participate in
the actually the process of scoring that
was Alexandre 100 and you it's
interesting because prior to composing
film I mean your wildly recognized as a
creative force in the pioneer of rock in
espanol and Alejandro was a disc jockey
right in Mexico some clubs for you over
there did he did he did he speak to sit
when he when you met him was it his was
he the one that was getting linty to
reach out to you or was it Leonard you
know no I actually actually think he was
really a sort of
[Music]
fascinated or was what really attracted
him to attract him was an album that I
did call wrong Rocco and that's what
really sort of attract attracted him to
meet with me and I think after we met
and we started talking and then I show
him what I thought with a guitar and
also the theme you know the main theme
which is kind of recurrent you know with
those kind of like dissonant and very
melancholic notes that really convince
him I know it was basically through the
Naraku that he he he was interested in
meeting with me and that was a song that
was in Michael Mann's the inside well
there's a there's a piece in my in the
album were broken that were used by
Michael Mann that actually was later
used also by Alejandro in Babel it's
called Yasu it's a piece that you know
it was abused by several people actually
but but but mainly I think it was the
instrument and and and the possibility
of working with that instrument to that
attract him but not because of the
Michael Mann I don't think he has seen
Michael Mann movie at the time you know
when we when we met so you've worked
with Alejandro and on four films in
total well I work in Amore's perros 21
grams yeah Babel and beautiful form yes
and was the process for all of those
films the same with Alejandro do you
feel like the subject matter changed
that no were they were different I mean
for 21 grams and for Babel I did a whole
bunch of the music a lot of music prior
to the film's being filmed actually you
know in this case I mean you know
Maurice barrows I already came to a film
when the film was there it was rough cut
but the film was there but in 21 grams
for example Alejandro played the some of
the music that I did a whole bunch of
music that I did for the actors and
actually some of the scenes I don't know
if you remember the movie but some of
the hospital scenes you know he
shut those ones playing the music on set
you know I mean while they were shooting
the hospital things the music became
part of in in 21 grams and in babel
intrinsic part of the film i mean you
know it was part of of the way I'd like
to work I'd love to work from the script
from the characters I mean that's the
same way I did with the Brokeback
Mountain to you know that was with angly
but say you know a lot of the music was
done prior in in the other two movies
and brought back almost all but in the
other hundred movies poster then the
beautiful the last one that one there
was music that we used that I did before
anything was shot but for me was for
that movie in particularly it was very
important for me to see and bar them to
see Javier's character you know see the
dailies and stuff that really helped me
to get into the music for that film so
in that one I think I took a lot from
watching dailies and stuff the other
ones I work a lot from the script you
know and if you read Alexandra's scripts
I mean they're just like what you see on
the screen I mean you know they're so
the description and everything is right
here lots of other films they change
quite a bit you know but his films
everything is written you know shots and
everything how do you decide what films
to work on I'm extremely extremely picky
and after after especially the films
that I've and the directors that I had
the chance to work I'm actually you know
looking for app I just finished a
documentary that I did with Lily's Anoka
Patti was a documentary about Eric
Clapton's life and I couldn't say no
because he is very clever and ask
especially like he wanted me to you know
see I couldn't say no and that that is
coming along right me just premiere in
Toronto I think we're gonna see it next
year but I'm you know I'm always trying
to find what is the right project to be
involved it's
it's special what I do and so I don't
think I fit like in the normal category
of film composers so I'm I was looking
for the movies that we were in which I
think I can I could add something you
know I could bring something more to the
movie and and also a movie or a story
that reverberates me that I can it's
something that I can connect with I read
that your career and body of work is all
about finding an identity can you can
you elaborate on that well I think I
mean in my music or in the artists that
I've been involved producing and I've
always like to somehow show you know who
I am and word where am i coming from you
know and I think that that part that
Argentinean part or that Latin part
shows up in everything that I do even in
things that you know like Brokeback
Mountain perhaps you know which is such
a piece of Americana right but I know
that in DES in those guitars that I play
you know in those silence and that you
know some of the stuff that I'm playing
it's very related to what a Wolper you
punky which is a guitar player you know
that I grew up an artist singer and
guitar player that I grew up listening
in Argentina is super connected to that
another example will be you know I
worked on a big video game called The
Last of Us you know huge looking for a
Sony Playstation and very very special
video game too
you know I mean I was contacted two
different ones I've never you know I
decided to do this one because I found
in Neil druckmann
the director writer is somebody that you
know somehow connects a little bit for
me with Alejandro to you know he's in
his vision well the theme the principal
theme of the Last of Us is done with the
wrong rocker
you know which is an instrument from the
Andes Mountains and
in a rhythm of 6/8 very connected to the
rhythm of Chiquita which is a rhythm
from Argentina you know and yet is a
game that you know happens in a
post-apocalyptic United States and it
Alejandro's is a director with
tremendous identity and I think the
movie obviously like Amore's perros you
know it's it's very easy to see that
because you know it's such a but in a
movie like revenant or any other movies
that he does for me there's an element
that only a Latin director could a fire
or whatever there's some elements in his
aesthetics in his approach to art that I
find very Latin you know to so I think
that's in a way when I when I talk about
identity that's when I refer to I
talking about Latino directors tell me
obviously there's Hollywood's diversity
problem it's something that's very much
a hot topic and I wonder what are your
thoughts about about the state of
affairs of Latinos in Hollywood well I
think you know that it's it's we know
that it's been you know sort of a if a
fight but it's it's been a long road in
which you know we're trying to to be
more recognized and be you know a part
of what is the whole world of not
Hollywood but I will say the whole you
know cultural world of the United States
you know and I always try to to think I
mean I think that I'll try to say and to
convey to people my thoughts about this
is that I really feel that the DNA of
the the United States today it is part
of the DNA of the United States it is
Latino I mean if you if you will you
know sort of examine what is the DNA of
you know that you can't leave latina
Latino out the Latino part of it is an
intrinsic part of what is the United
States today
so trying to
to avoid that or try to think about us
something you know would be the word but
but to sector eyes that you know I I
just think you know it defeats what
really is I mean today miletti you know
so of course part of the United States
we know once belonged to Mexico but
deeper than that deeper than that I
think you know I think today part of the
fabric of the United States it is it is
anglo-saxon and in this Latino we can't
separate it it's all part of this same
thing same fabric we had 30 years ago
it's hard to believe but Stand and
Deliver came out in La Bamba and so
there was a big wave of Latino films
American Latino films and then in 2000
we had a lot of specialist anything
about zombie and Frida and now recycle
diary Motorcycle Diaries and now we have
what do we have right now well I think
you know it's it's waves to and we have
to think that you know that that we
actually I think witness in the last 15
years a tremendous surge of a different
type of Latino that has come to this
forefront you know I mean we we were
used to for many years to our kid
archetype of Latino you know very which
I don't have any any problem you know
but but I just think you know that we I
don't think I mean everybody I think you
know know Stace you that we are not only
just you know in mariachis or you know
or Congress or trumpets or you know we
we you know we are much more than that
and I think with people like Alejandro
Gonzalez Inarritu achieve old wake
Alfonso Cuaron is a mall Toro I think
you know ourselves I mean Garcia Bernal
in the over loon I mean you know we have
a whole bunch of new Latinos that have
come to the to the forefront that show
another side of the Latino culture
which is perhaps one of the most typical
Latino you know but it but but but I
think enriches the view of what we as
Latinos are as a culture and I think
it's very very very important and we
have been experienced as this in the
last 10-15 years I think so you know
we'll know we'll see more and more I
think you know it's it's inevitable you
know what I mean it's part of what is
happening
there's no nonstop to this you know well
we've seen that growth in television
with Latinos and showrunners and writers
but all of the artists that you just
mentioned all come from Mexico or
Argentina and they're not us Latinos and
so Mike well I do the music for Jane
diversion to for example no right of
course what I'm just saying like might
men do its Hollywood and diversity it's
also you know I don't know if you what
is the answer how are we gonna get more
opportunities for the Latino community I
don't know it's just something that is
is you know on the forefront and
everybody's talking about so yes I
didn't know if you had any words of
wisdom in terms of making it in
Hollywood I really don't know because
you know in a way I don't know if I made
it in call you whatever well yeah yes so
I think the Academy has been tremendous
for me because you know it has been a
recognition that is beyond you know what
it can conceive but it's not necessarily
you know that that reflects you know in
every aspect for to every let you know
that is there you know I mean I've been
very lucky you know and not all in you
know not all the organizations you know
recognized but I think you know we need
more we need absolutely more presence of
Latinos in movies and television in
every aspect I think we need to reflect
reality if we don't do that we are not
reflecting what we see every day you
know in our daily life you know as I
said for me it's part of our fabric so
if it's in a way it's like denying it
we don't do it you know how to do it I
mean I don't know it's it's it's not
that easy you know yeah well I want to
thank you first of all for your for not
only I'm gonna spend uh so for all your
work which is absolutely 100% universal
and touches there's about one person I
don't care where they're on this planet
Earth that's not moved by your work and
your music it's absolutely stunning so
thank you for your gifts thank you and
that'll be all for this evening thank
you everyone for joining us
[Applause]
you
you